feeling a little under the weather think  you might need a doctor let's just hope  the doctor you get isn't scp-049  an intelligent supernatural monster also  known as the plague doctor he got his  name from his unique clothes heavy black  cloak and a bird-like plague doctor mask  but this doctor won't make you feel any  better in fact if he so much as touches  your bare skin you'll die instantly then  with this mysterious medical bag of  tricks the real work begins after  healing his dead patients they resurrect  as violent zombie-like entities only  then does he consider his subjects fully  cured of an unknown disease he refers to  as the pestilence despite his murderous  nature scp-049 has been reported to be  extremely intelligent polite and  well-spoken if you're an expert in  medical or scientific matters yourself  you'll have plenty to discuss with him  just don't get close enough for him to  make a diagnosis